[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
tochter heute möchte ich euch meinen weg
vorstellen und meine küche vorher mache
ich aber das frage-antwort-spiel ihr
habt mir nämlich fragen gestellt und ich
habe mir jetzt gedacht
wenig ist sowieso heute nichts kochen
oder backen und dann kann ich das ganz
wurde mit diesem video verbinden
deswegen werden wir uns die frage
gestellt und ich werde sobald es geht
beantworten
frage 1 nur etikette trägt ist sein
spitzname ist nicht so oft am netz zu
lassen ob sie nochmal streitkräften nur
etikett kräftig sein spitzname jahr
zähle ich mein spitzname ein richtiger
nachricht sei aber die wenigsten leute
können das aussprechen
meine wahl zum beispiel dann kann das
genauso wenig aussprechen und nennt
nichts zu sehen auch immer sally auch
wenn die eltern nicht sanierung
eigentlich abend meine freunde
es geht einfach schneller und einfacher
ist schäbig 61 48 fred wie alt und wie
groß bist du ich bin wahnsinnig werde im
august 25 bin bari 88 und ich bin 1
meter 75 groß
samir 3003 frägt was für eine
nationalität hast du ich bin als türken
in deutschland geboren meine eltern sind
irgendwann vor der halbzeit nach
deutschland gekommen und sich hier
kennengelernt und geheiratet haben hier
eine familie gegründet und ich bin eben
als tochter hier auf die welt gekommen
das heißt ich habe meine nationalität
ich kann also ich sage euch die tür
gehen aber ich bin auch zum teil
deutsche ich meine ich bin hier geboren
um bei mich kennt der weiß auch dass ich
besser dialektsprecher aus türkisch
ja also ich bin irgendwie so weit ist
007 kaffee fragt woher kommen deine
eltern ja das habe ich ja gesagt die aus
der türkei und woher aus der türkei
genau mein papa aus konya und meine mama
aus ersten inter elf fred bist du single
von gegen verheiratet mit wem drehst du
die videos ich bin vergeben
verheiratet seit etwa fünf jahren immer
noch mit dem gleichmann haha und drehe
manchmal meine videos auch mit meinem
mann dasteht und hinter der kamera
ab und zu habe ich auch schon mit meiner
freundin videos getrieben ein
allererstes video den lostopf habe ich
mit meiner besten freundin beträgt die
welt die auch bald wiedersehen das
versprechen und dann werde ich so schön
vorstellen
miss sixty fragt wer ist sehr gut aus
dem typen der kamera das sagt jasmin
herz 98 frägt wohnst du ich wohne in
waghäusel dass ich ein ganz toller ort
in der nähe von karlsruhe und mannheim
also sieg direkt zwischendrin er man so
schön in baden württemberg damit ist
auch immer scheint ja da wollen wir
unter fühlen wir uns wohl und mona fragt
woher kommst du dass du so einen
niedlichen akzent hast ja alles schon
gesagt aus waghäusel
ich spreche wisse trainerin susi
fledermaus fragt bist du eine schwäbin
so wie ich nee also ich bin keine
schwedischen partner
wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen an der
grenze und mal unterstellt mir mal den
schwedischer akzent
aber vielleicht ist das bisher
beeinflusst durch meinen mann sind ja da
habe ich mir einen schwarm für andante
als bankerin ist schillig 61 48 fragt
was machst du beruflich ich bin wärmt
anwärterin also einfach ein darin an der
ph in kassel studiert und und
hauptschullehrern und jetzt bin ich seit
februar aufeinander jagd es geht
eineinhalb jahre und danach hätte ich
dann hoffentlich bald lehrerin
welche fächer und an welcher schule
wirst du unterrichten
ich unterrichte an einer grundschule
unter einer werkrealschule und habe die
fächer haushalten textile deutsch und
englisch
die luxus fragt woher kannst du so gut
backen ist das dein hobby oder hast du
das gelernt kochen und backen ist
wirklich mein hobby ich mach das einfach
so nebenbei ich habe schon ziemlich früh
angefangen damit und ich habe es einfach
immer interessiert ja jemand habe ich
eben dann uns gedacht warum ich videos
drehen wenn du das schon so gerne macht
und deswegen mache ich das einfach für
euch hab dich ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
lieb mit welchem alter hast du das erste
mal gebacken
das ist gar nicht so genau und sagen
macht mich eigentlich immer in der küche
dir das nicht durch fakten noch
ich will ich denke so richtig vielleicht
somit breit sehen das so ja und somit
motiv toten habe ich vor drei jahren
glaube ich angefangen also so richtig
mit diesen von blöden passt so weiter ja
also seit drei jahren intensiv und davor
zu den letzten fünf sechs jahren wird
ganz normalen und davor einfach die du
bist nicht zufällig kunstlehrerin nee
also künstlerin hätte ich habe es
einfach als studiert weil ich sowieso in
meiner freizeit fehlbare ich habe mich
auch mal gesagt dass ich noch das zimmer
von meiner tochter abbauen möchte und
das ist dann vielleicht auch ein video
mit es dazu allerdings habe ich zurzeit
ein bisschen wenig zeit zum malen aber
ich denke später dass ich das doch auch
mal unterrichten wird gerade jetzt in
der grundschule macht man also wissen
eigentlich an laura s t fragt wer ist
denn bloß immer deine leckereien die
frage kann nicht beantworten das bin ich
meiner familie immer mehr nachbarn
ich wurde hier mit ganz vielen nachbarn
zusammen und die haben ein thema das
glück das ist genau was abbekommen meine
kollegen an der schule braucht sind ja
alle werden verwöhnt
jake berry fred hast du mal vor richtig
berühmt zu werden so im fernsehen oder
so ich finde es lustig dass jetzt die
frage kommt also werde ich möchte er
einfach mein hobby ausleben und meine
leidenschaft zum backen und kochen
teilen
allerdings ergibt sich wie gespannt was
wo im fernsehen nur darf ich das ist
der chef ganz so verraten aber so im
zwei drei wochen werde ich euch da noch
mal ein lied attribut sehen und endlich
verraten was da rauskommt melodie
ziemlich oft schräg wie es wie
eigentlich seine tochter eigentlich
meine tochter ist jetzt zweieinhalb
jahre alt und ziemlich aufgeweckt und
ansteigen und lebendig und süß natürlich
kommst 50667 fragt hast du vorbilder
sowohl beim backen alter im normalen
leben also mein größtes vorbild
natürlich meine mutter jetzt nämlich
geschafft fünf kinder haushalte um
arbeit unter einen hut zu kriegen also
fünf kinder will ich zwar nett aha ich
finde es schon ein paar hundert seit wir
unsere mütter und väter ist alles eben
auch so hinkriegen auch mein papa ich
mein großes vorbild da kriegen wir nicht
eigentlich alles hin was er wäre und
beruflich also so die lehrerin ist ja
ein vorbild an
also ich habe an meiner schule mehr
lehrer in meine mentorin des es mein
großes vorbild
die macht nämlich alles locker vom
hocker und was das backen und kochen
angeht mag ich so einige köche und
bäcker wird mich jetzt aber nicht auf
einen festlegen
also fragen was jetzt dieses mal ich
werde jetzt versuchen so vielleicht
einmal im monat oder eine 200 in frage
antwort video zu machen
je nachdem ob überhaupt fragen habt ist
ganz europa fragen bezüglich des bacchus
und kochens oder das kind einfach in den
videos rolls royce 20 denkt das bringt
jetzt nichts wenn ich das hier alles
erklärt und das eigentlich nichts damit
zu tun hat ich finde auf jeden fall toll
dass ihr so interessiert seid und mir
die frage stellt so ein paar namens sehe
ich ja immer öfter zum beispiel die ihm
ein großer fan
hallo oder die mir do listen gibt und
dann wenn ich kann ich aber ganz viel
also ich lebe eigentlich schon alle
kommentare durch auch wenig selbst
vielleicht nicht mehr schafft alle zu
beantworten aber das kommt auf jeden
fall alles immer bei mir an und ich
freue mich echte bewegen einzelnen
kommentar also ich habe jetzt noch
entschlossen dieses video als einzelnes
video hochzuladen
weil sie nämlich einfach da und so lange
wird mit werkzeugen deswegen
verabschiedet sich jetzt an dieser
stelle
mach gleich mit dem anderen video weiter
und ihr bekommt sondern schon mal dieses
video dann freue ich mich schon auf das
nächste und bis bald jeans
[Musik]
61 8 148 frägt sich das hoch bei 38 std